Another thing I want to discuss
is the implementation of a heap.
Though heaps are represented as trees,
they are actually often
stored as arrays.
How is that possible?
Well, since we know how many
children each parent has, two, and
thus how many nodes will be at each
level, we can use a little math to
figure out where the next node will fall
in the array and then traverse the tree.
Let's convert this sorted
array into a tree.
We know that the first element is going
to be the root since it's the biggest.
The next two elements in the array
are the children of the root.
By convention I insert
them from left to right.
However, that doesn't really matter as
long as they're on the second level.
Again, each level on the tree is
twice as big as the one before it, so
we know the next level
has four elements.
We can do this programmatically
by tracking the size of
each level in a variable, then doubling
it each time we move to a new level.
And everything left over fills in
the left side of the last level.
Now you're done.
Just a quick note.
Not every array can be
represented as a heap.
This one could because it was
sorted in descending order.
In general, the numbers need to be in
an order that will make sense on a heap.
Storing our data in an array
can save us some space.
If we use an array,
we just need to store the node value and
index in the array slot.
However, if we created some
kind of node object for
a tree, each would need pointers
to children and parents, so
we need to store values and
a bunch of pointers for every element.
Since the array saves us the pointers,
it saves us space.